vous voulez acheter un Mac en 2022 fin
2022 début 2023 voir peut-être même 2024
allez savoir quand vous allez regarder
cette vidéo alors je vais vous aider je
vais vous aiguiller on va essayer de
regarder quels sont les mains comment
acheter un Mac de quelle manière neuf
reconditionné à quel prix est-ce qu'on
veut un mac portable est-ce qu'on veut
un macbook est-ce qu'on veut plutôt en
acte de bureau est-ce qu'on va un iMac
est-ce qu'on va à Mac mini est-ce qu'on
veut un max studio est-ce qu'on veut un
Mac Pro bref quel Mac acheté en tout cas
tout de suite aujourd'hui fin 2022 début
2023 sujet passionnant intéressant
parfois un peu complexe parfois un peu
technique mais vous allez voir on va
s'en sortir allez c'est parti on y va
bingo
lorsque vous voulez venir acheter un Mac
il y a différentes façons pour y venir
l'acheter en neuf directement chez Apple
ou d'autres vendeurs ou alors venir
l'acheter reconditionné et ça tombe bien
parce que aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo
qui est réalisée en partenariat avec
Smart Smart avec 3 je vous avais déjà
parlé de Smart vous avez déjà visité
leur usine parce que Smart reconditionne
des smartphones mais aujourd'hui il nous
reconditionne pas que des smartphones il
reconditionne également des macs et
justement on va aller les voir dans leur
usine et vous allez voir comment ça se
passe c'est vraiment super intéressant
[Musique]
ici tous les Mac proviennent de France
déjà on peut venir tracer l'origine si
vous n'avez pas vu ma première vidéo je
vous parle de Smart je vous invite à
venir la voir parce que vous verrez les
valeurs Smart situé dans le sud de la
France tous situés ici que ce soit
l'arrivée des produits sont testés
reconditionnés réparés si besoin ils ont
une note tout le SAV là outline est là
ils ont même un centre de formation donc
tout est géré ici c'est vachement bien
c'est Green et ça on aime qu'est-ce que
fait Smart met en place tout en
processus de contrôle de test pour
s'assurer que votre ordinateur et pas
que les Mac également les PC parce
qu'elle est PC derrière soit testée
réparer pour s'assurer que infini il
arrive chez vous dans un super état le
truc extrêmement rassurant aussi c'est
que vous avez toute une batterie
d'experts qui va venir démonter et
réparer votre ordinateur disque dur
mémoire écran bref tout ce qu'il faut et
si tout est garanti 2 ans comme chez un
constructeur et l'avantage c'est qu'on
est 40 à 60% moins cher qu'en produits
neuf on a des circuits courts au niveau
des produits qu'on récupère au niveau de
la distribution également en France et
en Espagne ça donne plus de 80 %
d'économies positive pour la planète une
fois réparé hermie en état tous les
produits sont briqués nettoyés frottés
remis en carton pour ensuite arriver
chez vous les meilleurs conditions et
chez Smart vous avez la Smart Academy où
on va venir former des collaborateurs et
d'ailleurs il faut le savoir Smart
embauche donc si vous êtes pas loin du
Pic Saint-Loup ça peut peut-être vous
intéresser pour l'achat de votre Mac on
reconditionné venez chez Smart Smart
avec 3A
smart.fr je vous mets le lien juste en
bas dans la description et merci à Smart
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
[Musique]
regardez sur le site de Smart vous allez
sur la partie ordinateur et vous avez
les iMac reconditionnés entre autres ça
dépend des arrivages et là vous voyez
vous avez un iMac 21 pouces version 2017
i5 8 giga de ram on est à 619 euros
c'est quand même beaucoup plus cher
aujourd'hui un iMac 9 donc si vous avez
un budget un peu plus serré et que vous
voulez être sur Mac OS et bien aller
jeter un coup d'oeil sur Smart et merci
une fois de plus à se marre d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo alors on va
continuer on va regarder on va aller
directement chez Apple et on va essayer
de regarder un peu possible comprendre
quel type d'ordinateur il vous faut
alors c'est très clair déjà la première
question ça va être le format les usages
est-ce que vous voulez un ordinateur qui
va rester chez vous sur votre bureau ou
est-ce que à contre-ario un peu comme
moi vous prenez un ordinateur et vous
partez vous balader avec moi j'en ai
besoin tout le temps je suis très très
souvent déplacement donc j'ai toujours
besoin d'avoir mon ordinateur auquel cas
on va aller sur un MacBook mais les
MacBook a les MacBook Air il y a les
MacBook Pro on va avoir du MacBook Air
13 pouces du M1 avant du M2 et les
MacBook Pro on va avoir du 13 pouces on
va avoir du M1 on a du M2 on a de
l'Intel on a les MacBook Pro 14 pouces
16 pouces bref c'est un peu compliqué on
va venir dégrossir tout ça alors
regardez déjà on voit qu'il y a deux
types d'ordinateurs qu'on va pas trop
venir aborder c'est ce qu'on va appeler
le max studio et le Mac Pro veut pas
dire les appeler il s'appelle comme ça
le Mac studio et le Mac Pro pourquoi
parce que c'est plus des machines qui
sont destinées au professionnel à un
tarif beaucoup plus élevé là on commence
à 2299 €, on est quand même sur une
machine qui est très performante qui va
pas être faite pour tout le monde on est
sur de la puce M1 max sur la puce M1
ultra il faut vraiment venir aller sur
ces machines si on a des gros besoins de
performance si on veut derrière cet
article si on a besoin de faire de la 3D
si on a besoin de venir faire du montage
avec une machine qui est vraiment
vraiment puissante moi aujourd'hui j'ai
un macbook pro 16 pouces avec une puce
M1 max j'ai 32 giga de ram j'ai un
terrain de stockage voilà sur un MacBook
Pro parce que je me balade beaucoup mais
si vous voulez un équivalent en
ordinateur de bureau aujourd'hui chez
Apple vous allez sur le max studio vous
prenez la configuration à 2299 €, c'est
que le PC attention vous n'avez pas
d'écran vous n'avez pas le clavier vous
n'avez pas de souris vous n'avez rien
vous avez uniquement le cœur de
l'ordinateur vous êtes sur 10 cœurs de
donc 8 cœurs qui vont servir pour la
haute performance et deux cœurs qui
serviront pour l'efficacité énergétique
j'ai pu 24 heures autant dire que ça
déconne pas 16 coeurs de Norah el Angels
et puis vous avez 400 gigaoctets par
seconde de bande passante de mémoire
c'est vraiment une grosse grosse machine
et si vous allez beaucoup plus loin vous
avez la ultra bon là c'est voilà c'est
on est au-delà au-delà de tout super
machine 32 Go de mémoire donc pour tout
ce qui va être vidéo 3D on a besoin de
beaucoup de performances on va là dessus
c'est vraiment l'ordinateur de bureau
Apple aujourd'hui quand on veut
énormément de performances mais là
dessus il faut vraiment venir réfléchir
à venir rajouter des moniteurs et alors
chez Apple les moniteurs vous venez ici
et vous avez les écrans vous en avez
deux vous allez avoir le studio display
à partir de 1749 euros voyant en termes
de tarif ça pique un petit peu alors
après si on veut vraiment aller au top
du top du top vous avez le pro display
XDR qui sera pas forcément pour tout le
monde à partir de 5499 euros c'est une
machine extrêmement performante voilà
donc il faut vraiment réfléchir alors
après vous pouvez venir brancher hein
sur votre Mac un autre moniteur vous
pouvez aller par exemple chez Asus ils
ont très très bon moniteur qui seront
compatibles et que ils iront
probablement un peu moins cher donc
voilà pour le max studio alors après le
Mac Pro c'est la machine des très grands
professionnels qui veulent une machine
extrêmement performante c'est ce qu'on a
de mieux aujourd'hui chez Apple mais
voilà c'est vraiment pas du tout une
machine qui est destinée au grand public
qui coûte très très cher par contre
c'est une vraie bête de compète je vous
les évoquez très rapidement pour venir
voir mais si vous êtes un professionnel
si vous avez des usages spécifiques vous
savez déjà vous connaissez vous n'avez
pas besoin de cette vidéo là c'est plus
pour je dirais du conseil et de
l'accompagnement pour monsieur et madame
tout le monde qui veulent un Mac mais
qui ne savent pas lequel prendre alors
puisqu'on est dans la partie ordinateur
de bureau on va y rester alors on a deux
produits qui sont assez intéressants on
va voir le Mac mini qui est un peu comme
le max studio en moins performant vous
allez voir vous avez juste votre on va
appeler ça l'unité centrale que
l'ordinateur le Mac mini sans clavier
sans écran rien faut tout venir acheter
en supplément et vous avez l'image la
iMac 24 pouces ou là par contre vous
allez tout avoir un combo en entier
alors on va sur le Mac mini vous allez
voir le Mac mini c'est assez intéressant
c'est une belle machine en termes de
caractéristiques alors il vous propose
encore aujourd'hui en Intel très
clairement si vous allez sur le Intel si
vous allez sur du reconditionné des
machines moins chères pour aller sur un
Mac mais vous n'avez pas un très gros
budget si vous voulez acheter du neuf je
vous recommande vraiment d'aller sur une
puce M1 d'autant plus que le Mac mini
regarde en Intel il est à 1259 et sur la
main on est vachement moins cher pour
voir qu'on est sur une machine plus
performante ça vaut le coup donc moi ce
que je vous recommanderais réellement et
bien c'est de venir voir regarder vous
allez la pucement vous avez 8 cœurs au
niveau du CPU 4 coeurs de haute
performance et 4 coeurs pour
l'efficacité énergétique ok vous avez un
GPU donc le GPU c'est graphique le CPU
c'est au processeur que l'ordinateur
n'aura Legends pour tout ce qui va être
il y a derrière avec ses sœurs vous avez
8 Go de mémoire de base 16 gigas alors
si vous voulez faire de la vidéo
franchement avec un Mac mini vous pouvez
mais mettez au moins 16 Go de RAM parce
que 8 Go de RAM c'est marrant et vous
allez vraiment pas aller loin et une
fois de plus de la même manière je vous
conseille quand même de monter sur le
512 Go de stockage pourquoi parce que si
vous retrouvez bloqué avec un 256 c'est
vraiment cool de voir supprimer des
fichiers gnagnagna enfin bref dans le
temps c'est pas terrible donc moi ma rec
ici sur un Mac mini c'est deux parties
ici sur une M1 avec 512 Go vous êtes à
1029 euros c'est un peu plus cher en
termes de stockage vous y retrouverez
réellement et de venir upgrader ensuite
la RAM vous passez d'un huile vous
montez un 16 ça vient augmenter le tarif
mais au moins vous êtes tranquille alors
après on peut monter un terrain de
terrain bon 512 c'est vraiment le grand
grand minimum on a l'option pour monter
aussi en 10 giga bon ça dépend des setup
vous mettez déjà une base comme ça en
Gigabit Ethernet ça conviendra très bien
et voyez vous avez un ordinateur à 1259
euros sans moniteur sans clavier sans
trackpad sans souris donc ça il faut le
savoir bon à vous de voir si par contre
vous voulez vraiment tout en main
extrêmement cool et pratique vous allez
sur les iMac alors je vous dis
reconditionné chez Smart c'est vraiment
très cool vous en avez des pas trop cher
aujourd'hui en tout cas sur Intel et
plus tard ça arrivera avec Léana mais il
faut un petit peu de temps alors ça
c'est vraiment la machine très cool
parce que vous avez vraiment un combo
tout en un vous êtes déjà nouvelle gamme
qui est sorti il y a pas très longtemps
qui est super belle de toutes les
couleurs c'est frais c'est sympa ça
prend pas trop de place et vous avez une
machine qui est performante alors on est
plus ici sur de la bureautique plus plus
plus on peut faire un peu de vidéo mais
c'est vraiment pas la machine qui est
dédiée pour du montage vidéo un peu
poussé ni déjà 3D des choses comme ça
c'est vraiment leur dit familial vous le
voyez vous avez votre puce M1 8 heures
au niveau du CPU on a 8 heures au niveau
du GPU alors un très bel écran de 24
pouces ira très bien écran Retina 4,5k
ok ça ça me va très bien également on a
jusqu'à 16 Go de mémoire jusqu'à 2 Tera
vous avez
FaceTime donc votre caméra de selfie qui
est en 1080p ok ça ça me va bien donc on
a une machine qui est très très cool
alors moi ce que je vous conseille ici
sur la partie configuration tu sais ce
qui vous intéresse et bien regardez
alors vous voyez une petite différence
qui est assez intéressante vous avez ici
un CPU et huit heures partout et là vous
avez un petit GPU à 7 cœurs en version
sur la GPU à 8 heures alors une fois de
plus ça va réellement dépendre de vous
et de vos usages si vous avez pas de
vrai gros besoin graphique si vous
voulez pas trop venir un jeu sur votre
machine vous pouvez aller sur le setcœur
qui ira très bien attention ici vous
êtes sur 256 Go de stockage le truc qui
va être le plus intéressant c'est le 512
une fois de plus
1899 euros moi c'est ce que je viendrai
recommander mais bon une fois de plus
vous savez ce qu'on dit c'est les ceux
qui conseille c'est pas ceux qui payent
donc bon c'est pas moi qui vais payer
donc le mieux c'est quand même de se
rajouter 16 Go de RAM pour gagner un peu
en fluidité sur un 512 de base comme ça
alors après il y a un autre truc qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez la Magic
Mouse qui est compris avec c'est la
petite souris vous allez sur le côté et
vous avez le clavier qui est compris
également vous pouvez à la place de la
souris prendre un petit trackpad ou
alors faire carrément le combo entre les
deux avec trackpad et souris déjà avec
la souris comme ça ça ira très bien si
vous voulez le trackpad pourquoi pas
mais déjà avec la souris ça fonctionne
et vous avez le Magic keyboard qui est
compris donc ça veut dire qu'à 2129
euros vous avez une super configuration
ici et que je viendrai vraiment vous
recommander pour un ordinateur familial
à la maison en neuf acheter chez Apple
et je vous le dis une fois de plus un
tarif plus intéressant en reconditionné
mais on sera sur Intel de génération
antérieure qui fonctionnera bien pour de
la bureautique Mac mais auquel on va pas
faire tourner des jeux de fou auxquels
on va pas demander des choses trop
gourmandes ça il faut vraiment que ça va
donc voilà pour le côté un peu
bureautique à la maison alors si
maintenant on veut partir sur un
ordinateur portable avec lequel on va
venir se balader et se promener et si ça
et bien là on va arriver sur les
MacBooks alors là il y a deux questions
qui viennent se poser la question du
MacBook Air versus du MacBook Pro alors
on va commencer par le MacBook Air le
MacBook Air va être forcément un peu
moins cher il y a un peu moins loin que
le MacBook Pro on s'en doutera pour
autant vous avez un MacBook Air c'est du
13 pouces et vous avez également un
MacBook Pro 13 pouces qui existent vous
inquiétez pas je vais tout vous
expliquer alors MacBook Air vous avez
deux puces vous avez la M1 et vous avez
la m2 alors pour essayer de vraiment
comprendre on va venir ici on va
comparer MacBook Air M1 et on va se
mettre le MacBook Air m2 en face alors
regardez déjà vous avez quand même 300 €
d'écart alors 300 euros ça reste
beaucoup d'argent je suis d'accord avec
vous dites-vous bien que les max ça va
pas énormément d'écoter donc vous
pourrez le revendre dans quelques années
et vous le vendrez toujours plus si vous
avez une m2 que si vous avez une M1
parce qu'il y a deux ans quand même qui
sont passés entre la M1 qui est sorti en
2020 fin 2020 et la m2 en 2022 plutôt
début 2022 alors 13,3 13,6 ça change pas
réellement grand chose c'est intéressant
au niveau de du nombre de cœurs vous
avez 8 coeurs de CPU d'un côté comme de
l'autre par contre vous montez jusqu'à
10 cœurs de GPU au niveau niveau de la
m2 c'est quand même plutôt pas mal et
puis au niveau de la mémoire vous allez
monter un peu plus loin le stockage
sensiblement la même chose si on va
fouiller un peu du côté technique vous
allez avoir une plus grande bande
passante également regardez juste ici
100 gouttes par seconde de bande
passante de mémoire donc c'est pour ça
quand même un peu plus de fluidité c'est
quand même plus intéressant on s'en
doutera qu'on va aller un peu plus loin
que la m2 qui avait versus lime 1 on
peut monter jusqu'à 24 Go de RAM bon
très honnêtement le 16 ça conviendra
parce qu'on va pas avoir ici des gros
gros besoin en termes de puissance de
calcul alors après la question se pose
regardez c'est très intéressant c'est
sur la question de l'écran parce que
Apple il vous parle de Retina liquid
Retina on a du super étina on a du
liquide Retina XDR alors vous allez à
comprendre un peu tout ça Retina liquide
Retina c'est à peu près la même chose on
est sur un écran LCD c'est une dalle
IPES ok si vous montez sur du liquid
Rétina XDR on va le regarder sur les
MacBook Pro là vous êtes sur de la mini
LED donc des LED qui sont de taille
beaucoup plus petites versus de la LED
ça vous permettra d'avoir un gain de
luminosité un gain netteté et aussi sera
plus loin au niveau des contraste chaque
zone va venir travailler
individuellement par le bien de zone je
parle pas uniquement de l'aide mais
vraiment de zone parce qu'on n'est pas
sur l'oledoled c'est plus des comme des
pixels en fait qui vont venir s'allumer
indépendamment là c'est différent sur la
mini LED c'est plus des zones donc ça
permettra d'améliorer le contraste
l'image ça sera bien meilleur ça c'est
du liquide Rétina xD Et c'est pas ce
qu'on a ici ici ce qu'on a il vous le
marque sur la version 2020 écran rétro
éclairé par l'aide 13,3 pouces avec la
technologie
IPS ok écran liquide Rétina c'est dans
les deux cas du LED donc bon voilà on
est sur l'IPES dans les deux cas c'est
juste la dénomination qui change Retina
liquide Retina après c'est souvent la
densité de pixel qui va venir être
modula ici mais dans l'ensemble on est
sur les mêmes technologies derrière
comme ça il faut le savoir après le
reste on va être si vous êtes sur la m2
une meilleure résolution au niveau de la
caméra c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
pour venir échanger lors des conférences
avec la famille ici et ça on a quelques
petites améliorations audio également au
niveau de la m2 on s'en doutera
fatalement mais bon après ça reste dans
l'idée dans l'ADN à peu près les mêmes
produits avec le même nombre de ports
thunderbol USB 4 avec du wifi 6 d'un
côté et de l'autre je vous conseille
juste d'aller sur le MacBook Air m2
versus le M1 et pour 300 euros d'écart
très honnêtement vous allez réellement
en venir vous y retrouver maintenant je
veux qu'on vienne regarder ce qui se
passe du côté du modèle professionnel
parce que ça aussi c'est super
intéressant le MacBook Pro alors MacBook
Pro il vous le mettre sur leur site là
il y a vraiment deux parties qui
viennent séparer le MacBook Pro 13
pouces et les MacBook Pro 14 pouces et
16 pouces pourquoi parce que sur le 13
pouces il existe la M1 et la m2 on va
regarder ici tandis que sur le 14 pouces
et le 16 pouces vous êtes sur des M1 pro
et M1 ultra alors je vous le dis Franck
biais la Mapro et la M1 ultra seront
plus puissantes que la m2 dans l'attente
d'avoir une m2 pro une m2 ultra la m2
est meilleur que la M1 mais je vous dis
vous avez en gros la M1 la m2 et ensuite
au-dessus la M1 pro et encore au dessus
la M1 ultra c'est comme ça qu'il faut
venir le voir et si vous venez regarder
alors on va se faire les comparatifs
c'est là où on va quand même vachement
mieux sur le site d'Apple vous avez le
Pro 13 pouces de 2020 avec la M1 et vous
avez le Pro 13 pouces avec la M partir
de 2022 et comme sur les MacBook Air je
vous recommande réellement devenir sur
la version 2022 avec la m2 de toute
façon regardez vous le vendre plus
aujourd'hui chez Apple l'autre version à
partir de 1599 euros alors vous allez me
dire ok monsieur greu 1599 €, mais si je
regarde mon MacBook Air m2 de 2022 et
bien j'ai 100 euros d'écart 1499 versus
1599 alors est-ce que ça vaut le coup de
mettre encore 100 € de plus pour arriver
sur un modèle professionnel et là vous
allez regarder c'est vachement
intéressant regardez on va descendre un
petit peu bon ok écran les couilles
Retina latina bon ça on vous expliquez
ça à peu près la même chose le
processeur elle-même donc on va voir le
même nombre de CPU si le même nombre de
GPU jusqu'à 10 cœurs mais bon bah à peu
près la même chose on va aller monter
jusqu'à la même config au niveau de la
RAM même nombre de stockage l'autonomie
sera un peu meilleur sur le modèle Pro
alors attention regardez ça commence un
petit peu à ce moduler ici on voit que
sur le modèle Pro vous avez la touch bar
et touch Heidi bon ok pourquoi pas je
suis pas sûr que ça change bien un peu
la face du monde la config est
sensiblement la même d'un côté comme de
l'autre donc bon il y a vraiment pas
énormément de différences ce qui peut
être intéressant c'est que sur le
MacBook Pro 13 pouces vous avez une
caméra HD 720p versus 1080p sur le
MacBook Air il y a quelques petits
modifications qui sont pas énormes donc
ici il m'a très honnêtement ce que je
vais venir vous recommander et bien
c'est d'aller sur le MacBook Air m2 vous
avez 100 € d'écart mais c'est 100 €, ils
sont pris et pour la différence je vous
recommande d'aller là-dessus maintenant
et c'est là où ça devient super
intéressant on va regarder les Mac et on
va venir ici au niveau des MacBook Pro
et on va venir surtout au niveau des 14
pouces et des 16 pouces pourquoi parce
que là vous avez une vraie différence et
là on arrive dans tout autre chose c'est
là où le modèle professionnel devient
réellement intéressant alors regardez
une fois de plus on va venir au niveau
du comparatif pour que vous voyez
réellement de quoi on parle on va venir
comparer ces deux machines on va se
mettre ici le MacBook Pro 14 pouces
l'autre côté le MacBook process pousser
la même génération ils sont arrivés en
même temps si tu le taille de dalles qui
vont être modules le 14 pouces on est à
partir de 2249 euros c'est quand même
cher 2749 euros pour le modèle à 16
pouces vous êtes dans les deux cas sur
un liquid Rétina XDR c'est ce que je
vous disais c'est du mini LED donc une
14 ou 16 pouces de 2021 c'est que très
honnêtement vous voulez beaucoup de
performances et que vous avez besoin
d'énormément de performances donc si
vous voulez un macbook air si vous
voulez une machine qui est très bien qui
est performante vous allez pouvoir faire
du montage vidéo ok mais si vous voulez
aller plus loin il faut switcher sur le
Pro vous avez besoin de beaucoup de
performances même pour faire de la
musique avec Logic c'est totalement
optimisé pour la puce M1 donc si vous
allez sur logic vous allez avoir un truc
qui fonctionne du feu de Dieu tout
dépend du budget pour moi j'ai tendance
à dire que le MacBook Air de 2022 et
très cool avec la puce m2 mais le
MacBook Pro 14 pouces et 16 pouces la
seule chose qui va venir changer c'est
la compacité du produit moi j'ai un 16
pouces il est quand même hyper gros le
truc qui est intéressant c'est que vous
aurez beaucoup plus de port sur le
modèle 16 pouces moi j'ai voyais du côté
là je vais avoir du HDMI j'ai un acteur
de cartes SD j'ai trois Thunderbolt 4
USB cap ça marche bien donc vous voyez
la question elle vient vraiment se poser
là parce qu'après il y a vraiment la
différence de tarif là sur le MacBook
Air c'est une machine qui est très
polyvalente qui est quand même puissante
attention on est quand même sur les
choses puissantes 1499 euros et on
rajoute presque 1000 balles 800 voire
plus si affinités pour arriver sur le
modèle Pro donc posez-vous vraiment la
question de vos usages si vous avez des
usages sur de la bureautique un peu de
montage un peu de retouches de photos
peu de vidéos mais sans trop bourriner
vous allez sur le MacBook Air m2 c'est
la très bien si maintenant vous avez
besoin de beaucoup de performances et
bien vous allez sur le MacBook Pro 14
pouces ou le 16 pouces avoir si vous
voulez regarder ma je vous montre ma
config moi je suis sur un 16 pouces moi
j'ai la M1 pro j'ai intérêt de stockage
donc moi je suis juste ici et après vous
allez venir upgrader votre machine par
rapport à votre mémoire regardez vous
venez ici soit vous restez sur le pro ça
pouvait passer sur le max et encore deux
configurations sur le max mais là ça
waouh ça explose le truc et moi je suis
sur 32 Go de mémoire donc vous voyez la
machine que j'ai je suis déjà à 3439
euros ça reste quand même un très gros
budget mais c'est une super machine donc
la question à se poser c'est est-ce que
vous avez besoin d'un mât qui restera
qu'à la maison ou est-ce que vous allez
être nomade si vous restez à la maison
et que vous voulez une machine qui
fonctionne bien sont beaucoup trop de
performances vous pouvez aller regarder
sur de reconditionnelles et jeter un
coup d'œil chez Smart si par contre vous
voulez un truc qui est très performant
actuel et bien vous allez directement
comment acheter sur le site d'Apple ou
via les liens que je vous mets juste en
bas dans la description et si vous
voulez une machine que vous allez
emmener partout avec vous avec de la
performance qui va très bien qui sera
pas la machine avec de la performance
brute et bien vous allez sur un MacBook
Air m2 de 2022 si à contrario vous
voulez une machine très performante vous
allez sur les MacBook Pro 14 pouces ou
16 pouces de 2021 avec la puce M1 pro
qui a très bien la MMA max vous faut le
maximum de performances et là vous allez
avoir un truc de fou donc voilà sur
cette gamme aujourd'hui pour savoir quel
Mac acheter fin 2022 début 2023 c'est
très complet voyez il y a plein de
choses mais comme ça on dégrossi puis on
arrive un petit peu à avoir vers quelle
machine se dirige alors j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura aidé vous aura
intéressé je vous envoie une fois de
plus à tous les liens en bas dans la
description puis si vous avez des
questions des idées des suggestions vous
pouvez les marquer bien évidemment dans
les commentaires quant à moi je vous
embrasse ton rendez-vous très bientôt
pour continuer à parler tech à vous
aider dans vos achats vous montrez plein
de nouvelles technos ici sur Youtube
mais également sur Tik Tok sur twitch
Instagram real Facebook watch j'en passe
des meilleurs je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]